Jake: 换了个脸型
Jake: Changed the face shape.
Jake: 整容大整容
Jake: Big makeover.
Lucia: 对然后我从后面再画五官
Lucia: Yeah, and then I'll draw the features from the back.
Lucia: 但我觉得现在这个反正定位还行
Lucia: But I think the positioning is okay now.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Lucia: 所以我先剪下来试试
Lucia: So I'll cut it out and try it first.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 但是其实我最开始的那个它才是
Lucia: But actually, my original one was the right size.
Lucia: 它才是合比例的大小
Lucia: That one was the correct proportion.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 所以我现在有点虚
Lucia: So now I'm a bit unsure.
Jake: 没事很多板
Jake: No worries, we have plenty of boards.
Jake: 最不缺板
Jake: We never lack boards.
Lucia: 希望这个定位是准的
Lucia: Hope this positioning is accurate.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:数据倒完了吗竹哥
Jake: Have you finished transferring the data, Bamboo?
Jake:数据倒完了吗
Jake: Have you finished transferring the data?
Nicous: 卧槽 忘了
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure:  我记不住了
Shure: I can't remember anymore.
Jake: 我先把这个先冲掉
Jake: Let me rinse this off first.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 薇薇做狗吗
Jake: Tasha, are you pretending to be a dog?
Tasha: 不做
Tasha: No.
Jake:不做狗
Jake: No dog?
Jake: 我就两条看门狗
Jake: I only have two guard dogs.
Tasha: 哦靠
Tasha: Oh, come on.
Jake: 就 是吗
Jake: Right, isn't it?
Jake: 就是别人家里面是俩石狮子
Jake: Other people have stone lions at their entrance.
Jake: 咱俩看门狗
Jake: We have two guard dogs.
Jake: 这是什么品种
Jake: What breed is this?
Lucia: 管他什么品种
Lucia: Who cares what breed it is.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 我已经放弃专门搞一个品种出来了
Lucia: I've given up on figuring out a specific breed.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Tasha: 你干嘛要拿这个纸
Tasha: Why are you taking this paper?
Jake: 拿这个纸擦一下
Jake: To wipe it with this paper.
Jake: 里边
Jake: Inside.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 我看起来是整完了
Jake: 啥意思啊
Jake: What does that mean?
Tasha: 宠物宠物殡葬师
Tasha: Pet funeral director.
Jake: 呵呵呵我去
Jake: Haha, oh my god.
Jake: 我可算想起来刮胡子了啊
Jake: I finally remembered to shave.
Jake: 我可算想起来了
Jake: I finally remembered.
Tasha: 想起来什么
Tasha: Remembered what?
Jake: 把胡子刮了
Jake: To shave.
Tasha:哇
Tasha: Wow.
Tasha: 等会就有最需要你的活了啊
Tasha: Soon you'll have the most important job.
Jake: 什么搅和
Jake: What job?
Jake: 打蛋液
Jake: Beating eggs.
Jake: 打奶油
Jake: Whipping cream.
Tasha: 拉拉面团
Tasha: Kneading dough.
Jake: 拉面
Jake: Making noodles.
Jake: 有意思
Jake: Interesting.
Jake: 我们要干嘛来着
Jake: What are we doing?
Jake: 我们要
Jake: We...
Jake: 小贝
Jake: Little Bei.
Jake: 是吗
Jake: Right?
Jake: 肉松小贝
Jake: Meat floss cake.
Jake: 还是
Jake: Or...
Jake:面团是干嘛的呀
Jake: What's the dough for?
Tasha:做麻薯用的
Tasha: It's for making mochi.
Jake:做麻薯
Jake: Making mochi.
Tasha:肉公小贝还做吗今天
Tasha: Are we still making meat floss cake today?
Tasha:我在问你
Tasha: I'm asking you.
Tasha:我不是在
Tasha: I'm not...
Jake:呃 我们要 嗯麻薯是要单独的
Tasha:甜品
Tasha: Dessert.
Jake:可以做呀
Jake: We can do it.
Jake:做吧
Jake: Let's make it.
Jake:怎么十分不愿意的感觉
Jake: Why do you seem so reluctant?
Tasha: 没有没有
Tasha: No, no.
Tasha: 一切听您的指挥
Tasha: I'm completely following your lead.
Jake: 那可
Jake: Well then...
Jake: 开
Jake: Go.
Jake: 嗯 来 验收 哈哈
Jake: Hmm, come on, let's inspect. Haha.
Shure:  可以很棒
Shure: It's great.
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: It's good, it's good.
Jake:合唱也行
Jake: Chorus is fine too.
Jake:可以
Jake: It's okay.
Jake: 应该还没有
Jake: Maybe not yet.
Jake: 可以啊可以
Jake: It’s fine, it's fine.
Jake: 整个乐队
Jake: Whole band.
Jake: 可以啊
Jake: It's okay.
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Shure:  我们还刚刚即兴创作了一首歌
Shure: We just improvised a new song.
Jake: 来请
Jake: Come on, please.
Jake: 哦好啊
Jake: Oh, great.
Jake: 研究研究
Jake: Let's study it.
Jake: 这是开情歌了
Jake: Is this a love song?
Jake: 是开始了吗
Jake: Is it starting?
Shure:  完了唱太多别的
Shure: Finished singing too many others.
Shure:  我把我刚才自己
Shure: I just...
Shure:  你们给我放一遍
Shure: Can you play it again?
Shure:  我刚才那个我草
Shure: What I just... damn.
Jake: 确实比solo比那个苏罗要强
Jake: It's definitely better than the solo, better than Su Luo.
Shure:  哈哈是吧
Shure: Haha, right?
Jake: 比苏罗AI
Jake: Better than Su Luo AI.
Shure:  苏罗就是AI
Shure: Suro is just AI
Jake: 我给你我给你放一个苏罗AI
Jake: I'll show you, I'll show you Suro AI
Jake: 好啊好啊
Jake: Sure, sure
Jake: 要不伴个舞吧你就
Jake: How about a dance?
Jake: 哈哈哈伴个舞吧要
Jake: Hahaha, how about a dance?
Shure:  我们可以唱心造的人
Shure: We can sing "Created by Heart"
Jake: 哈哈哈可以啊
Jake: Hahaha, sure
Jake: 你在这迎宾
Jake: You greet the guests here
Shure:  可以吧你看这种就是旋律很洗脑
Shure: Look, this kind of melody is really catchy
Shure:  是
Shure: Yes
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:是
Jake: Yes
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm
Jake: 对
Jake: Right
Jake:给一个style
Jake: Give a style
Jake: 给一个music style
Jake: Give a music style
Shure:  happy metal
Shure: Happy metal
Jake: ok
Jake: Ok
Shure: 它生成的happy metal都非常的抽象的
Shure: The happy metal it generates is very abstract
Jake: 哦真的吗
Jake: Oh really?
Jake: 真的好嘞
Jake: Really?
Shure:  之前那个让我们荡起双桨重金属
Shure: Like that previous one, "Rowing the Boat" in heavy metal
Jake: 我草 哈哈哈
Jake: Damn, hahaha
Shure:  这真的是happy metal吗
Shure: Is this really happy metal?
Jake: 没有没有
Jake: No, no
Jake: 这是pop他默认是pop
Jake: This is pop, it's defaulted to pop
Jake: 这对味了对
Jake: This is the right taste
Jake: 哇他有歌词吗
Jake: 等一下
Jake: Wait a minute
Jake: 这是不是要
Jake: Is this supposed to
Jake: 我把电脑搬出来了
Jake: I brought out my computer
Jake: 呵呵呵这手机好像他不出歌词
Jake: Haha, this phone doesn't seem to produce lyrics
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Damn
Jake:哎对
Jake: Right
Shure:  还有烤地瓜
Shure: There's also roasted sweet potato
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Jake: 这经济繁荣
Jake: This is economic prosperity
Jake: 局部经济繁荣
Jake: Local economic prosperity
Jake: 我吃一个
Jake: I'll have one
Jake: 可以吃吗
Jake: Can we eat this?
Jake: 应该可以吃
Jake: Should be edible.
Shure:  好香啊我靠
Shure: Smells so good, damn.
Shure:  这皮他是不能吃
Shure: You can't eat the skin.
Shure:  他酥了
Shure: It's crispy.
Shure:  我说这皮都能吃
Shure: I mean, you can eat all the skin.
Shure:  感觉
Shure: Feels like...
Jake: 我靠
Jake: Damn.
Jake:绝香
Jake: Absolutely fragrant.
Alice:烧烤摊上就是这种
Alice: This is how it is at barbecue stalls.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 干
Jake: Cheers.
Shure: 干一个
Shure: Cheers.
Shure:  干地瓜
Shure: Dry sweet potato.
Shure:  直接给我翻译成什么
Shure: How do I translate this?
Jake:：groundmelon
Jake: Groundmelon.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: 来重金属摇滚
Jake: Let's rock with some heavy metal.
Jake: 有声
Jake: With sound.
Jake:这不对啊
Jake: This isn't right.
Shure: 这不对啊
Shure: This isn't right.
Jake:这不对呀这不对呀
Jake: This isn't right, this isn't right.
Jake: 是不是听不懂中文啊
Jake: Do you not understand Chinese?
Jake: 哇只会pop吧
Jake: Wow, you only know pop music?
Shure:  好pop呀
Shure: So pop.
Shure:  no style more her heavy metal
Shure: No style, more her heavy metal.
Jake: 谢彬竹玩嗨了
Jake: Xie Binzhu is having a blast.
Jake: 第一回玩吗
Jake: Is it your first time?
Jake:但他弹过钢琴
Shure:  我靠还给他化妆
Shure: Damn, even got makeup done.
Jake: 是是挺是挺可爱哎呦
Jake: Yeah, it's quite cute, oh dear.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 我专门睁大眼睛
Jake: I purposely opened my eyes wide.
Lucia: 因为不好不好打草稿
Lucia: Because it's hard to draft.
Jake: 还有大眼睛
Jake: And big eyes.
Jake: 噢
Jake: Oh.
Jake:噢
Lucia: 表情包模式
Lucia: Meme mode.
Jake: 他不会
Jake: He can't.
Jake: 你得给他歌词
Jake: You need to give him the lyrics.
Tasha: 好了你可以把地瓜放下了
Tasha: Alright, you can put the sweet potato down now.
Jake: 我杵哪了
Jake: Where was I standing?
Jake: 我杵这了
Jake: I'm standing here.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure:  有可能是个引子哦
Shure: It might be an intro.
Jake: 一个引子
Jake: An intro.
Jake: 就是大伙可以给词他他词写的不行
Jake: So everyone can give him lyrics, his lyrics are not good enough.
Jake: 如果觉得你觉得怎么样
Jake: What do you think?
Jake:确实还行
Jake: Actually, it's okay.
Shure:  很含糊哇哈哈哈这个节奏
Shure: It's very vague, hahaha, this rhythm.
Jake: 哈哈哈完了
Jake: Hahaha, it's over.
Jake: 人机大战
Jake: Man vs. machine.
Shure: 我败下一程居然
Shure: I actually lost.
Katrina:  好看
Katrina: Interesting.
Alice: 第一
Alice: First place.
Tasha:第一
Tasha: First place.
Jake: 我要干什么
Jake: What am I supposed to do?
Jake: 啊我要搅和吗
Jake: Ah, should I mix it?
Tasha: 把它们揉在一起
Tasha: Knead them together.
Jake: 哎呦
Jake: Ouch.
Jake: 哎呦好烫啊
Jake: Ouch, it's so hot.
Tasha: 这还烫啊
Tasha: This is still hot?
Tasha: 已经凉了好久了
Tasha: It's been cool for a long time.
Shure:  我输给AI了我靠
Shure: I lost to AI, damn.
Shure:  确实
Shure: Indeed.
Jake:哈哈哈但是没有记忆点
Jake: Hahaha, but there are no memorable points.
Jake: 我觉得对
Jake: I think, yeah.
Jake: AI他这没
Jake: AI doesn't have...
Jake: 哎呀我靠好烫啊
Jake: Ah, damn, it's so hot.
Tasha: 不好意思要不你脱下来吧
Tasha: Sorry, maybe you should take it off.
Jake: 哎呀
Jake: Ah.
Tasha: 我以为已经过了好久了
Tasha: I thought it had been a long time already.
Tasha: 那那等会你再来搅
Tasha: Then you can mix it later.
Shure:  这就非常草东味你知道吗
Shure: This has a very Grass East flavor, you know?
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Alright.
Shure: 就是那个中间那个嘣嘣嘣嘣
Shure: Like that middle part, boom boom boom boom.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:啊好烫啊
Jake: Ah, so hot.
Shure:  你可以拿这个
Shure: You can use this.
Jake:哎呀你看一下手机怎么回事
Jake: Hey, check your phone, what's going on?
Jake:没空间了是吧
Jake: No more space, right?
Jake: 呃不算挤
Jake: Uh, not crowded.
Jake: 不挤不挤
Jake: Not crowded, not crowded.
Alice: 我的狗录上了吗
Alice: 应该怎么最后没有
Alice: How come there's nothing in the end?
Tasha: 吃吗
Tasha: Want to eat?
Jake: 啊也没有interaction
Jake: Ah, there's no interaction either.
Shure:  对这个间奏还不错
Shure: Yeah, this interlude is pretty good.
Jake: 没关系拿过来直接用
Jake: No worries, just take it and use it directly.
Shure:  这才是happy metal
Shure: This is happy metal.
Shure:  但这这没词
Shure: But there's no lyrics.
Jake: 这没词
Jake: There's no lyrics.
Jake: 沙雕他这写词很沙雕的
Jake: Sand sculpture, his lyrics are very sand sculpture.
Alice:这个要不要传
Alice: Should we upload this?
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh...
Jake: 我看一下他是是没空间了还是什么
Jake: Let me check if it's out of space or something.
Alice: 应该录了有快3个小时了
Alice: It's been recording for almost 3 hours.
Alice: 我做小狗之前还有40多个G
Alice: I had over 40GB before doing the puppy.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm...
Jake: 啥意思呢
Jake: What does that mean?
Jake: 我刷一下刷
Jake: Let me refresh it.
Jake: 这个是我从那个
Jake: This is from my...
Jake: 我同学把把那个
Jake: My classmate copied his...
Jake: 他的Wei page直接copy过来
Jake: His Wei page directly and gave it to me.
Jake: 就给写了一个
Jake: Just wrote one.
Shure:  这个才对
Shure: This is correct.
Shure:  你刚刚旺仔中间加个分号了
Shure: You added a semicolon in the middle of Wangzai.
Shure:  加个分号才才能
Shure: Adding a semicolon is the only way.
Jake: 哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Jake: 哎是没录吗
Jake: Hey, didn't it record?
Alice: 录了因为我在
Alice: It did, because I...
Katrina:  做小狗之前
Katrina: Before doing the puppy.
Alice: 我之前还有只有40多个g
Alice: I still had over 40GB before.
Jake:那好奇怪
Jake: That's so weird.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake: 我我我试一下我试一下试一下
Jake: Let me try, let me try, try it.
Jake: 什什么情况
Jake: What's going on?
Jake: 什么情况
Jake: 笑什么
Jake: Why are you laughing?
Jake: 我也江苏人
Jake: I'm from Jiangsu too.
Jake: 但是我是很我
Jake: But I'm really...
Jake: 我那时候还是病题作文
Jake: Back then, I was writing essay prompts.
Jake: 我我那时候还命题作文
Jake: I was still writing essay prompts back then.
Jake:不画不画不画嗯
Jake: No drawing, no drawing, no drawing, hmm.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Shure:  哦你们只选两科
Shure: Oh, you guys only choose two subjects?
Jake: 对当初就是我
Jake: Yeah, back then it was just me...
Tasha:我我
Tasha: I, I...
Jake: 能录吧这个啊
Jake: Can we record this?
Jake: 能录吧哈哈哈
Jake: Can we record this? Hahaha.
Alice:有吗
Alice: Is it recording?
Jake: 没有
Jake: No.
Alice:没有吗
Alice: Not recording?
Jake: 这一下午都没有
Jake: Not all afternoon.
Jake: 应该是不知道为什么可能是崩掉了
Jake: Probably crashed for some reason.
Jake: 没关系吧没办法
Jake: It's alright, can't help it.
Jake: 可以你对你可以对没关系
Jake: It's okay, you can, you can. It's fine.
Alice:给小狗录像
Alice: Filming the puppy.
Jake: 来来写一首特朗普之歌
Jake: Come on, let's write a Trump song.
Shure:  别别别
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure:  哎我们来命题作文battle吧
Shure: Hey, let's have an essay prompt battle.
Jake: 来
Jake: Sure.
Shure:  大家随便出个题
Shure: Everyone come up with a topic.
Shure:  然后让他写和让我写
Shure: Then we'll both write on it.
Shure:  看看哪个更牛逼
Shure: See who's better.
Jake: 那出个题
Jake: Alright, come up with a topic.
Shure:  来出个题
Shure: Come up with a topic.
Shure:  就随便说
Shure: Just say anything.
Jake:谢彬竹之歌吧要不就
Jake: How about a song about Xie Binzhu?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  AI不知道谢彬竹是什么
Shure: AI doesn't know who Xie Binzhu is.
Jake: 没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake: 我也给他形容一下
Jake: I'll describe him.
Jake: 谢彬竹是一个什么什么什么啊
Jake: Xie Binzhu is a...
Nicous: 谢彬竹是一个被吃了就会自动说谢谢的虫
Nicous: Xie Binzhu is a bug that says thank you when eaten.
Nicous: 在海边长大的
Nicous: Grew up by the seaside.
Jake: 可以 就这个
Jake: Alright, let's go with that.
Jake: 你你这像是叫什么
Jake: You, you sound like...
Jake: 以前考状元的那种电视
Jake: Those TV shows where they take exams.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake: 好也可以
Jake: Okay, that's fine.
Jake:北冰洋吧
Jake: Beibingyang.
Shure:  北冰洋
Shure: Beibingyang.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake: 北冰北冰洋
Jake: Beibing Beibingyang.
Jake: 北冰洋的什么
Jake: What about Beibingyang?
Jake: 唇唇膏
Jake: Lip balm.
Shure:  北冰洋的熊猫
Shure: Beibingyang's panda.
Jake: 北冰洋的熊猫噢
Jake: Beibingyang's panda, oh.
Jake: DK音乐
Jake: DK music.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Shure: 北冰洋的熊猫是吗
Shure: Beibingyang's panda, right?
Jake: style
Jake: Style.
Shure: style你随便
Shure: Style, whatever you want.
Jake:我我随便
Jake: I, I don't mind.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 哦我靠
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Jake: 喂
Jake: Hello?
Jake: 喂哎呦我去啊
Jake: Hello? Oh my gosh.
Jake: 你好呵呵你好你好
Jake: Hi, haha, hello, hello.
Jake: 来了来了来了来了
Jake: I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
Jake: 帮我帮我敲敲吧啊
Jake: Help me, help me knock, please.
Jake: hello hello哎哎哎你在哪啊
Jake: Hello, hello. Hey, hey, hey, where are you?
Jake: 哎呦可能看到你了
Jake: Oh, I might see you.
Jake: 我穿个短袖啊
Jake: I'm wearing a short sleeve shirt.
Jake: 你好
Jake: Hi.
Jake: 好谢谢你
Jake: Okay, thank you.
Jake: 在这
Jake: Here.
Jake: 请进
Jake: Please come in.
Jake: 31往前请
Jake: 31, please go ahead.
Jake: 在前面就到了
Jake: It's just up ahead.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 哦就两桶是吧
Jake: Oh, just two buckets, right?
Jake: 我靠那我没手了
Jake: Oh my gosh, I have no hands free.
Jake:哎好
Jake: Alright, fine.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thank you.
Jake: 小心啊小心啊
Jake: Be careful, be careful.
Jake: 要不走上去
Jake: How about we walk up?
Jake: 帮我拿一下吧
Jake: Help me carry it, please.
Jake: 来谢谢你啊
Jake: Come on, thank you.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 上来吃饭吧
Jake: Come up and eat.
Tasha: 吃完就去把面团揉了吧
Tasha: After eating, go knead the dough.
Jake: 哎好
Jake: Sure, okay.
Jake: 这个温度应该合适
Jake: This temperature should be right.
Jake: 什么曲子呀
Jake: What song is this?
Katrina:  北冰洋的熊猫
Katrina: "Panda of the Arctic Ocean."
Jake: 有词吗在这是吧
Jake: Does it have lyrics? Is it here?
Jake: 不是这个
Jake: Not this one.
Jake: 我我以前喜欢给他写的
Jake: I used to like writing for him.
Jake: 就是直接给他style OP
Jake: Just giving him a style OP directly.
Jake: 对就是animation OP啊
Jake: Yeah, like an animation OP.
Jake: 就是
Jake: Just...
Jake: 就感觉北朝与战士的那种那种东西
Jake: It feels like the kind of stuff from "Northern Dynasty and Warriors."
Jake: 永不什么
Jake: Never what?
Shure:  永不窒息
Shure: Never suffocate.
Jake: 永不窒息
Jake: Never suffocate.
Jake: 大熊猫永不窒息
Jake: Giant pandas never suffocate.
Jake: 嗯他默认应该都是流星
Jake: Hmm, it's usually meteors by default.
Shure:  我不能受他牵连
Shure: I can't get involved with him.
Shure:  我要构思我自己
Shure: I need to come up with my own ideas.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 上吧
Jake: Go ahead.
Jake: 走上去弹吧
Jake: Go up and play.
Jake: 上去配个乐吧要不就
Jake: Go up and add some music, or...
Jake: 饭店驻唱
Jake: Sing at the restaurant.
Jake: 哈哈哈那李先生
Jake: Hahaha, Mr. Li's.
Jake: 李先生面馆
Jake: Mr. Li's noodle shop.
Shure: 前面得给我立个二维码
Shure: Put a QR code in front of me.
Shure:  好吧哈哈哈
Shure: Okay, hahaha.
Jake: 李先生面馆驻唱
Jake: Mr. Li's noodle shop singer.
Jake: 首席驻唱
Jake: The chief singer.
Jake: 哎不对 不抬了
Jake: Wait, no, don't raise it.
Shure:  这个反正是一人一份
Shure: Anyway, it's one portion each.
Shure:  这种有个座吃就行
Shure: Just having a seat to eat is fine.
Jake: 哎对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 蹲着吃都行
Jake: Even squatting is fine.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Shure:  赶早好吧
Shure: It's good to be early.
Jake:好哦
Jake: Okay
Shure: 这是
Shure: This is
Jake:这我的
Jake: This is mine
Shure:  每人三个
Shure: Each person gets three
Jake: 什么意思
Jake: What do you mean?
Jake: 我操哈哈哈
Jake: Oh crap, hahaha
Jake: 你服了我操
Jake: I'm impressed, oh crap
Shure:  臭汉次元滚出去
Shure: Stinky Han dimension, get out 种族宗教问题
Jake: 哼这不行了
Jake: Hmm, this won't work
Jake: 来一个
Jake: Let's do one
Jake: 考虑啊你
Jake: Think about it, you
Shure:  你是不是私宅
Shure: Are you a private residence?
Shure:  真恶心啊
Shure: So disgusting
Shure:  要不我坐小孩那桌去吧
Shure: How about I go sit at the kids' table?
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright then
Jake: 我靠 一
Jake: Oh damn, one...